It's already April.
Usagi miraculously
got into Juban High School.
Mamo-chan easily
got accepted into medical school.
And I grew up to be a great Guardian,
so I decided to
go back to the 30th century.
Father, Mother,
please be there to greet me!
The sunlight is
too bright for the elderly.
I feel at ease at night.
We must act fast
to make our circus show
succeed in this town.
Isn't that right, Zircon?
Are you listening,
my girls?
We know, old lady.
You can count on us,
the Amazoness Quartet, the orb masters!
We must prevent
any obstruction of our business.
I won't tolerate even a single
unsightly bug entering our circus!
We need to fully seal the entrance then.
The cursed stone
passed down among the Amazoness,
Amazon Stone!
Tama-no-Kouburi!
Moon Cosmic Power!
Moon Prism Power!
-Make Up!
-What?
-Well…
-Gosh.
Why can't we transform?
-Oh, my.
The Holy Grail…
Moon Crisis Make Up!
The Pretty Guardian.
In a Sailor Suit Guardian
of Love and Justice.
Super Sailor Moon!
Super Sailor Chibi Moon!
In the name of the Moon,
-I'll punish you!
So you're the ones
who tried to break our barrier. How dare you!
-What?
-A barrier?
We'll finish you both.
Tama-Yobai!
Oh, Lemures! The embodiment of nightmares!
Get them good!
Go!
We need to attack.
We need a weapon to defeat them!
Helios, please!
Give us a weapon!
Twinkle Yell!
What?
Super Sailor Moon!
A kaleidoscope?
Those crystal kaleidoscopes
desire a strong connection with you both.
They're the Moon Kaleidoscope
and the Chibi Moon Kaleidoscope.
Get them, Lemures!
Moon Gorgeous!
Meditation!
What?